大多數交易者在剝頭皮交易中失敗
並不是因為他們的入場點不好
而是因為他們在市場沒有真正壓力的情況下進行交易
價格移動幾個點
停止
突然會彈
突然之間
看似容易的
剝頭皮交易變成了餘損
在一分鐘圖表上
這種情況經常發生
在本視頻中
我將向您展示一個非常簡單但功能強大的一分寸撥頭皮策略
專注於極端價格波動和快速反轉
如果您正確理解規則
它可以為您帶來很高的勝率
讓我們開始吧
次策略轉為快速執行而設計
因此我們在一分鐘時間框架上操作
我現在在Trading View上
此設置使用三個指標
一個ADX和兩個肯特納通道
Keltner Channels
我們將非常精確的設置他們
首先電機車指標
搜索ADX平均取向指數
並將其添加到圖表
添加後打開設置
您可以再次出操作
將ADX平滑設置設為12
DI長度也設為12
本視頻的設置到此為止
然後在ADX上添加一條水平線
并将其精确设置在30水平
因为此水平将作为我们的确认过滤器
如果无法精确设置在30
您可以双击盖线
这将打开设置
再次出可以将左标设置为30
这样就会将盖线精确设置在30水平
30水平
如果ADX高于30
则波动性足够强可以进行交易
如果低于30
我们则保持官网
之后添加肯特纳通道
我们需要两个
因此再次打开指标选项卡
搜索Keltner Channels点击两次一天加两次现在打开第一个指标的设置对于第一个肯特纳通道将长度设置为无时
乘数设置为3.75
设置完毕
现在打开第二个肯特纳通道的设置
对于第二个肯特纳通道再次将长度设置为无时
但这次乘数应为2.75
然后赚到阳世界选项卡
將所有肯特納通道組件設為白色
一邊結構在圖表上清晰可見
現在設置已完成
這是一個基於波動性的波頭皮策略
而非趨勢跟蹤策略
這意味著我們專門針對市場過度拉升
然後迅速回攤的極端價格波動
因此與趨勢策略相比
此策略風險更高
這也是風險管理在刺出絕對直觀重要的原因
核心思想很簡單
我们只关着价格达到交款肯特纳通道及外部通道之外的极端水平式
当价格宏击或移动到该交款肯特纳通道之外时
它告诉我们市场一过度拉伸,短期反转可能发生
但我们不会立即入场
首先价格必须返回并在内部肯特纳通道及白色通道内收盘
该白色通道内的收盘乍者是我们的第一个条件
第二个条件是ADX
我们检查此时的ADX值
如果ADX低于30即使设置看起来完美
我们也不采取任何行动
如果ADX高于30则表明波动性足够强
现在反转更有可能持续
您是否觉得身边的每个人都在从人工智能中受益
但您却不知道从哪里开始
不要再等了
今天就开始吧
我们的免费交易机器人使用简单
由人工智能驱动
每天可为您带来高达1%的利润
已有5万多名会员加入
现在就点击下面的链接获取免费使用权
这是你利用人工智能的力量向财务增长迈出一步的机会例如这里借格移动到外部肯特纳通道上方然后回到白色通道内但ADX低于30
因此我们跳过此次交易
同样的情况再次发生在这里
极端波动会车止白色通道内
但ADX仍然疲弱
因此没有入场信号
在这里在这个例子中
我们再次看到价格超出外部肯特纳通道
返回在白色通道内收盘
而这次ADX明显高于30
这确认了卖出交易
因此当新扎着开盘时
我们可以进入卖出仓位
此策略设用于任何市场
无论是外汇加密货币还是股票
只要资产具有良好的流动性和娇小的点差
这一部分极为重要
因为在剥头皮交易中
我们进行大量交易
目标是小的价格波动
如果市场交易良地
电差大或存在价格缺口
可能会完全破坏您的入场
止损和盈利
因此情势中选择流动性高的市场
接下来您将在买入段看到相同的逻辑
让我向您展示在进行试盘交易时典型
设置会是怎样的
在这里
我们可以看到价格机具推值交宽
肯特纳通道的下跪下方
因此目前我是要也不做
我只是在观察
这告诉我价格已达到极端水平
但这本身还不够
我等待
接下来我想看到的是价格会车并在白色肯特纳通道内收盘
随着乍者向前推进
您可以看到价格开始放换
最终这只乍者完全在白色通道内收盘
我的第一个条件完成
现在我立即将注意力转移到ADX上
此时ADX高于30水平
这告诉我此次波动背后有力量支撑
不仅仅是随机噪音
此确认直观重要
没有它
我会跳过此次交易
既然两个条件现在都已满足
我等待下一根扎着开盘并再次出进入卖路交易我的止损设在近期极端的点下方略地于肯特纳下跪
为交易留出足够的喘息空间
我将置应设置为风险的1.5倍
随着价格继续向前移动
您可以看到反应是清晰的
价格平稳上涨
尊重通道
并在短时间内宏极致影
这正是高质量拨头皮买入交易应有的样子
不猜测
不提前入场
不追张
只有耐心和确认
现在让我向您展示一个实时迈出实力
再次使用回方
一边毫无保留
我让图表前进
您可以看到价格急剧扩展直角款肯特那通道的上柜上方
这里即使我进入境界状态
但我仍然是要也不做
极端并不意味着入场
我等待价格回落
几根榨子之后借格开始下跌
最终这根榨者重新在白色肯特纳通道内收盘
这是我第一个表明极端波动可能即将耗尽的信号
现在我检查ADX
您可以清楚地看到此时ADX高于30
确认了强烈的波动性
这是绿灯
当下一根榨者开盘时
我再次出进入卖出交易
我的止损设在近期高点上放
略高于肯特纳上柜以控制风险
直音再次设置为风险的2倍
1.5倍
这就是您在拨头皮交易中希望看到的
快速反应
强劲的后续走势
市场毫不犹豫
现在整个策略最重要的部分是
风险管理
这是一种高频
就是基于波动性的拨头皮方法
因为我们针对极端波动进行交易
与损失游戏的一部分
如果您不控制风险
您的账户可能会很快被清零
这就是完整的解析
如果您有任何问题
请在评论区留言
我会恢复您
如果您尚未订阅
请无比订阅并开启通知
以免错过下一个策略
感谢您观看视频直到最后
我们下个视频再见